pour le meilleur et pour le pire
jusqu'à ce que la menace est mort oui
j'aime ils se sont dit oui et elle leur
a dit oui un gâteau de mariage ça
représente la personnalité des deux
personnes qui vont une et c'est anna
batissiel designer geneviève leclerc que
arminé guillon ont confié la conception
du gâteau geneviève à dégager quelque
chose de vraiment positif
elle a une énergie qui dépassent
l'entendement et les montres la maison
il m'a dit j'ai trouvé notre parti
sierre est vraiment bonne ce pouvoir
sans voir ses heures
sa part avec la rencontre avec les
futurs mariés nous en parle de quantum
on parle aussi de décor on parle des
gens peuvent avoir sur la table y croire
jobs comme mcavoy est le suivant c'est
moi que la prime à la casse avant de la
montrer comme ça va être par rapp amour
au tchèque est vrai que c'est nous ce
qu'on voulait mettre l'avancé jumelage
nos cultures
elle a tout compris puis elle a proposé
l'idée était de reprendre notre faire
part leur gâteau fait sur trois étages
l'étagé du centre ya un éléphant je peux
vous montrer ici c'était sur le rapport
que j'ai fait par après à la main serait
de la fantastique je vais le peinture
est un peu avec du bord des fleurs et de
la verdure qui va ressortir que me
réservent un gâteau les gens si souvent
un an à l'avancé
on reste en contact vraiment pendant un
an ou pendant le délai qu'on entre les
deux mois pendant ce temps la saison je
fais de la recherche
le gâteau de mariage avec toujours été
un élément central de la fin ça vient de
la crise
à ce moment là les invités y avait des
grosses galettes de sarrasin et corse et
ce sur la tête des mariés et ses
supposés d'apporter prospérité abondance
bonheur fertilité donc c'est cette
tradition là qu'on a fait perdurer qui
s'est transformé en dessert qui s'est
transformée par la suite en pièces
montées où l'homme et la femme copains
ensemble et ça symbolise le premier
geste du couple à faire ensemble
maryse noël et planificatrice de mariage
depuis plus de 15 ans des gâteaux elle
en a vu en 2019 les grattons un peu
l'effet de pierre soit de marbre de
pierre un peu de toile à l'aquarelle
aussi sarsan masse puis la nouvelle
affaire que j'ai vu cette année c'est
andré qui saïd écoute le glaçage et des
belles coule et se dorer tout ce qui
vient d'angély vient encore une fois la
mode est en train de changer justement
on est quelqu'un que ce qu'on voit le
gâteau travers le jeu promet laquelle je
l'appelle comme ça j'ai juste comme ça
cette façon de faire de nos gâteaux
d'alluré plus rustique
j'ai mis ma petite tête cette statue
c'est ce que geneviève a proposé aux
futurs mariés et gâteaux je dirais que
c'est la star convainc mariage pour
rentrer dans la salle la première chose
qu'on cherche c'est pas sa place le
braiment gâteau les gantois autant ça
fait majestueux plus gros râteau et
vas-y j'aime ce camp que ces onze c'est
impressionnant aussi bord sur une table
ok donc plutôt du dessus la génoise et à
la cardamome une crème framboise
recouvert d'une crème à l'eau de rose et
à l'intérieur et des pistaches
concassées le pauvre homme qui contient
aussi un laitage du milieu c'était
génoise à la limite avec une crème aux
fraises
et puis pour les tagètes du boss et une
génoise fanny egy b de rhum brun est
guéri
il a passé en faut savoir que armin est
d'origine indienne moi je suis d'origine
martiniquaise africaine française fait
que c'est un gâteau qui mixe aussi bien
au niveau de ses saveurs mais aussi bien
au niveau de sa décoration qui va
rappeler justement nos origines
on oublie des fois que ça se mange ça
sent pas la rose
moi je me sens à chaque fois comme si je
faisais du bricolage faut pas juste que
ça soit beau faut que ça soit bon aussi
pour la cardamome justement but est la
première fois il faut faire vite et donc
j'ai fait des cuissons avant vous envoie
ce que j'en dis merci pour aux as et il
faut que ça goûte mais pas trop avec les
autres à voir
avant c'était plus vanille chocolat
quelque chose de plus classique
maintenant on a du citron ne des trucs
fruité avec des vrais fruits dedans
vraiment la qualité des ingrédients des
saveurs et dans le gâteau aussi dans
cette pâtisserie on confectionne plus de
200 gâteau de mariage par année
jean de plus en plus ils veulent des
gâteaux de l'alliance avec tous
sochaux les gens sont de plus en plus au
courant des nouveautés des tendances et
ils veulent des gâteaux de mariage aussi
élaboré on s'assoit avec nos clients ont
fait une consultation on leur fait
goûter 6,7 choix de gâteaux pour
l'intérieur du gâteau et ensuite on
discute au niveau du
détail le ch'ti
en leur montrant des gâteaux pour dans
un magasin pour la grandeur être tout ça
a un prix il faut calculer entre 8 et 12
$ la portion gâteau de mariage c'est un
passe temps au moins six ans et plus ça
peut aller jusqu'à 2 3 médailles
pour des gros gâteau à 10 12 étages
d'euros pour geneviève créer un gâteau
de mariage ses recherches détail
patience et rigueur
c'est quand même quelque chose il
vraiment beaucoup détergent pas juste
cuir groupe et enfin un gâteau au pardon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]